so let's try this let's make a global
variable called sagas that will store an
array for us and we'll use this array
for storage of saga functions then all
we would need in order to have permanent
access to each of these saga functions
is to push them into that global array
at that point we could choose to access
these functions even outside the scope
they were defined within the invocation
of those saga functions could actually
happen after the new saga function that
created them was done running so let's
try moving these lines of code down here
in between the two calls to new saga
just to see how it would work let's try
running this code with our simulated
interpreter again so this first line of
code will create an array and put it in
a global variable called sagas and this
will be where we store each of the saga
functions eventually then the line that
assigns a new value to the hero variable
will run and create some random string
in this case boy to store into the hero
variable new saga is yet another
assignment so a function object gets
placed into the new saga variable and
we're ready to do a lookup of new saga
find this function object and invoke it
because of those two parens invoking any
function creates a new context and that
context is where all the lookups will
start so first we add another variable
to that context foil foil is randomly
selected to be rat and here's the
interesting part the sagas array is now
stored in a global variable which means
calls to that push should have a lasting
effect on it the persist even after new
saga has finished running what do you
think is going to be added into this
sagas array as a result of this line